[Musique]
voilà deux semaines que les vendanges
ont commencé en alsace jusqu'au mois
d'octobre les viticulteurs auront besoin
de bras pour récolter le raisin une
activité saisonnière en manque de
main-d'oeuvre ces dernières années pour
cette saison à colmar les 2100 offres
d'emploi publiées nous recueilli que
1300 candidature en cause la baisse du
chômage dans la région
dans le haut rhin pour pallier en partie
à cette pénurie de main d'oeuvre on mène
une expérimentation depuis deux ans en
proposant des allocataires du rsa
d'aller travailler dans les vignes
c'est la deuxième année que le conseil
départemental du rhin met en place ce
dispositif rsa vendanges qui permet un
bénéficiaire du rsa de cumuler
l'allocation rsa et le bénéfice du
revenu des vendanges
l'an dernier nous avions 187
allocataires du rsa qui ont fait les
vendanges et les viticulteurs étaient
très contents du travail qu'ils ont
fourni
c'est un outil parmi d'autres qui
facilite la la promotion des ondes de
l'emploi dans l'est dans les vignes
pendant la période des quatre mois où on
peut travailler dans les vignes
principalement et ça ça favorise pour
ces publics aux bénéficiaires rsa la
possibilité en termes de revenus d'aller
travailler d'accepter ce travail dans
les vignes avec un cumul allocations rsa
et revenus d'activité
le principe du dispositif permettre aux
locataires de cumuler les revenus tirés
du travail dans les vignes et
l'allocation rsa sur ce dispositif
l'allocation serait retranché des
salaires perçus voire annulées ce qui
peut dans le cadre d'emplois de courte
durée comme ces contrats saisonniers
être un frein pour les allocataires
ceci ne souhaitant pas voir leurs
revenus durablement réduit pour quelques
semaines de travail pour le conseil
départemental et le pôle emploi qui mène
l'expérimentation c'est aussi et surtout
une façon de remettre les allocataires
les plus éloignées de l'emploi sur les
rails
une reprise d'activité un de retrouver
un rythme de retrouver une régularité de
respecter vos cils et les consignes
qu'ils ont lu leur est donnée dans le
cadre du contrat de travail proposé
ça fait partie des enjeux pour des
bénéficiaires rsa effectivement sur ses
187 bénéficiaires un tiers plus d'un
tiers ont trouvé un emploi ce qui veut
dire aussi que ce dispositif permet de
recréer du lien social et permet le cas
échéant de trouver un emploi j'ai en
tête des exemples de bénéficiaires du
rsa qui ont fait les bandages l'an
dernier et qui in fine et ont été
recrutés dans le cadre d'un contrat à
durée déterminée par le viticulteur chez
qu'ils exerçaient côté viticulteurs ou
s'estiment satisfaits de cette main
d'oeuvre si les aux cater du rsa ont
plutôt mauvaise presse dans l'opinion
dans les vignes ceux qui ont travaillé
les dernières ont plutôt laissé un bon
souvenir
on se rend compte aussi que les
bénéficiaires du rsa qui l'an dernier
ont fait les vendanges sont des
personnes engagées qui veulent
travailler
ce sont souvent eux qui était à la tête
des équipes de vendangeurs sur le
domaine dire les à bergholtz pour les
vendanges ce sont 25 personnes
saisonnière et permanente qui vont
intervenir cette année un allocataire du
rsa les a rejoint
du point de vue de son employeur c'est
un salarié comme les autres c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on demande de but en
blanc
quand on recrute parce que c'est pas
toujours
très valorisant de dire qu'on bénéficie
du rsa mais effectivement on ne savait
pas que thomas en bénéficier mais bon ce
n'est pas un problème pour nous une
jeune personne un très motivé une bonne
personne et c'est vrai que on est
content qu'il puisse bénéficier de ce
dispositif de maintien de du rsa durant
les vendanges
voilà mais on on compte également
l'employé
après les vendanges pour la descente de
bois ou du liège
enfin pour d'autres travaux voilà le
cumul du rsa et d'un travail salarié
dans les vignes est possible durant les
quatre mois autour des vendanges pour
remplir l'objectif d'insertion
professionnelle et sortir les deux
locataires du chômage de longue durée au
pôle emploi ou vise sur la formation en
complément donc que l'emploi à colmar
nous avons fait le choix d'acheter une
formation spécifique tractoriste
professionnalisation des métiers de la
vigne destiné aussi à développer des
compétences spécifiques pour des
demandeurs d'emploi pour accéder aux
emplois durables et pérennes proposé par
les viticulteurs
enfin au conseil départemental au vu du
bilan positif de cette action on
réfléchit déjà à l'étendre à d'autres
secteurs dans le aura nous allons
étendre ce rsa à vendange également au
rsa cueillette des fraises et le rsa
asperges puisqu'on sait que dans le
domaine du maraîchage et bien on manque
beaucoup de personnel pour les autres
domaines d'activité comme le btp
nous avons mis en oeuvre cette année
d'autres dispositifs des contrats aidés
qui permettent et bien à l'employeur qui
prend en charge dans le cadre d'un
emploi un bénéficiaire du rsa de
bénéficier de 40 7% dette du département
le dispositif mis en place depuis 2008
dans le haut rhin le bas rhin et deux
autres départements fait des petits déjà
cette année trois nouveaux départements
ont fait le choix de le proposer à leurs
allocataires